POLITICS, CAMPAIGN AND WHAT SHE
TO DO IF
COMPSS OWN REBRITY MOMENT YETYN
>> Reporter: A
MEDAL FOE DECATHLON IN 197AND IS
BOX, AEA TV DAD  KEEPINGE KARDA
TRANSITION TO CAITLYN WITH A
"VANITY"ERAND SHE'S  A RAC RECAC
RANCH IN MALIBD EXPLNED
WHY.
>> DURINT WA
WO MORNING LIKE
WHAT D TODAY
YOU CAN' ABSOL
, YOU KNOW.
IT JUST  MY.WHEN I THINKING
THIS, BECAUSE I'LWS FOLLOWEDICS
HER POLITICAL
INVOLVEMENT WAS LIMITED.
SHE BACKED DONALD TRUMP IN6 FRO
POLICIES.
WHAT KIND OF T YOU
HA TR OF
LI AN UR.NK YOU'VE BESHAND REAL,
I'ONE THATINESS AND YOU HAVE TO
A THINGS.
WE SOLD A BILLIOLL
OFRCISE EQUIPMEN
TELEVISION.
PAVEN INVOLVED
BEINAN
Y CHILDR TO
SAME THING A THEY'VE DE N  DEPAA
THLI EXPERIE A
T MT IMPORTANT
THINISR. ATE, THIISFTH LARLD.
.
>> Reporter: YOUL QUALIFIED
YES, BECAG TO
SUOUF WITH SOM
BUDGET PEOPLO PRSEter: CAN YOU
BUE'LL JUS A
E
I DON'O EXPOSE ANYBODY.
I HAWITH THEISNE JUSLIKE
SO SMART, BEEN WORKING
ON REGULATIONS IN THIS STATE FR
I SAID OH MY GOD, U'E MYNEW BES?
IT PEOPLE LIKE THATHAT IL N  A
LIKE HTHE ABILIT
ATTRAC SACRATHAT CAN IFFERENCE.
APPEAL TO CALIFORNIANS THAT FEEL
OVER BD ER TAXED.
>> I WOULDE S.
FRE ONS, NO MORETAXES, EVERYBODP
BREATH AND LET'S SEEWE CAN
>> Reporter:
Y
CE.
S.ES. AXES, A FREEZE ON NE
>> Reporte I DON'T THINK
GOVERNOR NEW SO MUSK LEFT CALIFA
COO YOU THINK A
BILLIRKE TAXED?
LL CALIFORNIANT MIAX ALS BE FAIE
ABOUT A 5%SOMETHING.WH
S IN CALIFORNIA, HOW WE
ARE TAXED -- YOU WALK
DOOR AND YOU'RE  START BEING TA
>> Repr:O ASK A
LITTITNAL
OH
REMEMBERNNING FOR
CALIFORNIA.
>> Reporter: INOW.
OT A NIOL
>>or
NATIONAL POSITION BUT YOREE ANRU
KNOW, TO BE DIICAN SO LET'S TAL
WERE STOLEN  HIM.  UH-HUH.
YO EE  PRESIDENT.OU, DO
ECT THAT.
I REALIZHERE'S A
T  OVETH
I' OVER WHATPPED, BUT WHAT
HAVE I DONE?
OK
I WANTOM IT?
>> THE THEN TRUMP CAMPAIGN WENT
LAWSTSE WAS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
WAS ANYTHING- ARE YOBLE
TH THAT?
DO YOUE ELECTION
WASTOLEN?
ARE A DEMOCR HAVE ITY IN OURE FE
ELONM.
I'M NOT GOING TOO ON PAST,
YO.
>> ARE WE, THOUGH?
>> WE'RE I'T THINK H WARD. I'M
YOU'REEPUBLICAN -- YH,D OF OE
REPUBLICAN SIDE --
DO IT. BECAUSE I HAVE CONSERVATI
ECONOM PHILOS THE
ONLY THING THAT THE REPUBLICAN
ARE KIND OF ON THA I
THN'T KNOW, MAYBE YOBE YOU CALL
ONWHEN
IT COMES TO SOCIAL ISSUES, I'M
>>IFORNIA HAS LONGR ON COMBATOVO
AGGRESSIEDUC
GREENHOUSE.FORNIAN AM
WISH SHOWSOA RELYING ON
EMISSIOY
DETERMINE AT WHAT INLA PROBAULDE
GOING TO COME UP2045
WEE ROMIWHAT WNE T
FOLLOW.OF SMART PEOPLE
OUT THER TO GET, MRO EMISSIONS L
GO LESS AND I ULARE TO SANTA MO.
YOU COULDN'T EVEN TAINS IN PAS
EVERY DAY THROUGH TH'70s AND
'8, EVERY DAY ON THE NEY
WOULD HAVE THE SMOALERT, THIS
IS WHAT THE SMOG IS.
TAVE THOSE ANYMOR
SEE THE S. S THAT BECAUSE OF  LO
ING THE LAWS THAHAVE BEEN
AREY AGGRESSIVE IN FAVOR OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AGAINST SS
FUROBABLHEO
YOU TO SEE ICA ABOUT
WOULD YOU PUE INLACE?
KEEGS IN PLACE
BUT I'M NOT --FUEL W
WE'RE GOING TO HAVR
TMAY NOT EVEN BTATHIS
WE WILL HAVERG
SOURCEBUT FOR THE TIME BEING, F
AR PROPERTY, JENNEE FROM ATING
AND SHOWS US
AN E BARN.  LAST COUPLE YEARS
GREAT FOR .IENDSI'VE H H NEED EA
KENDALL ANE HAVE HORSES
D YBE TH TO BRING THEM OVER ATe
CHILENAMTE
INCLUDING FOUR KARDASHIAN
STEPCHILDREN.
ANY OFIL
CAMP WYOU?
>> HERE IS THE DEAL.
QUESTION.
MY KIDS ARE NOIN EVER WTHIS.
D THEM -- NESTLY, I
AND I
THME AND I HEAT RELATIONSHIP BUT
THE MEDIA IS TO DO. FAMILY HART
DOT I SAID I AM NOT
GOING TO ASK YOU FOR ONE TWEET.
I'T GOIN FOR ONEUR
THIS IMY DECISION
TO AND GL THE MEDIA STAY AWAASK.
N YOURDAUGHT>>E KIM AND I SHE'S
G EAWI JUSTICETED IF I -- BECOMI
WOULD FOLLOW HER GUIDANCE IN
REHABITI IT, BUT IAS BEE,  GOODH
DON'T HAVE HEROLGN AT ALWHATSOE
>> I CAN'TER
DISCUSSED IT BUT SHE'S
I LOVE KIMBERLY.
SM GREAT BES
AND VERY D